the show is sponsored by expressvpn stop
putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com yang
[Applause]
at this point the newspaper industry has
gotten rolled up and consolidated into
a handful of uh operators that are
themselves owned by private equity firms
who are now ringing them for cash
that fact is playing out during covid in
the sense that if
if you remember after after 9 11
it happened in one town well two towns
dc but primarily one town
the new york times the hometown
newspaper did these
amazing portraits of people who had died
uh you know the the more than two
thousand people that had died
um and it you know you really connected
with them
as as people who had lost their life
because of this national tragedy
well we've now had what the equivalent
of 73
911s or something like that
and local newspapers are not doing those
kinds of stories
because they don't have a while the
the the kind of bandwidth that
that they should have and and profiling
people in their community that have died
because of covid
unless you personally know somebody that
died there's not
the kind of connection to this tragedy
that we had we all had with 911
because of what the new york times was
doing with these portraits
[Music]
happy thanksgiving hope that you're
celebrating
and warmth and love with family and
friends
maybe just family give it this
thanksgiving
uh we've got a special thanksgiving
episode of yang speaks
i interview pete souza and who the heck
is pete souza you're thinking i've heard
that name i've heard that name
he was the white house photographer for
all eight years
of the obama administration
i actually got to benefit from his work
he took a number of pictures of me
uh which at the time i was like ooh like
this photographer good
and now we're interviewing him it's very
heartwarming he's also the subject of a
documentary
that's out now uh how i see it that's
about his
work uh and his contrasting the obama
administration with the trump
administration
in visual form uh it's a great
documentary
he's one of a kind he's like the
photographer of history
hope you enjoy it happy thanksgiving
pete souza
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks maybe the best known photographer
walking the planet today he was the
white house photographer under president
obama uh
and has done a lot of things both before
and even since
pete souza welcome pete yeah thanks for
having me on andrew i appreciate it
uh i appreciate the heck out of your
being here it's so fun
uh and um i don't know if you know this
but you took
my picture in the white house a couple
of times um
i don't suppose you remember oh
i had i i photographed a lot of people
coming and going
so i'm going to regale everyone with
this story because i think a lot of
people
dream about visiting the white house and
whatnot
i got invited there as a champion of
change in 2012
as i was 37 years old at the time
and uh pete was there taking pictures
of the gathering there was a group of us
with president obama
and then one of the most delightful
things about the entire experience
was that then you go with pete down the
hall
to this photo alcove
i would describe it and then pete takes
your picture
you get like a mini individual white
house photo
courtesy of one of the greatest
photographers of all time
and then they send it to you afterwards
and it becomes your profile photo
it's like the greatest experience in the
world i i don't know
if you realize how impactful those mini
photos that you did uh of guests were i
don't i mean
i guess you've talked to people like me
all the time so everyone tells you
you know you know certainly certainly
was aware how important those were
uh for for uh people especially if it
was their only time meeting
president obama you know it's it's a
keepsake for them so
um you know and i think my office did a
good job working with all the different
points of contact
at the white house to make sure that we
did get
those pictures out of the people so that
they would have
their keepsake photo that they could
then make their profile for them
it really was it was like uh like the
ultimate
school yearbook photo like revved up to
a thousand um so i'm sure a lot of
people would want to know
um how the heck do you get a job as a
white house photographer
it seems like there are so many
photographers uh throughout
the country um and uh you know
photojournalism it's something that
makes me really sad
i'd love to talk to you about this too
where i feel like as a field
it's shrinking uh in large part because
so many of these
newspapers are folding and that the
newspapers would be the primary
the magazines too the print magazines um
so before we get into kind of the future
of photojournalism how did you
develop and then wind up with maybe the
highest profile
photojournalist gig in the world
well i mean let me preface this by
saying that given where we are today
which is um
you know not long after joe biden has
been elected i think
a lot a lot of people reaching out to me
saying i want to be
joe biden's photographer and you know
and my response to them is
i try to be blunt and go if if joe biden
doesn't know you
now he's not going to hire you you know
i mean there's
he's had a campaign photographer for the
last two years
you know that that's the guy that's
likely to get the job
for me uh i i just by you know sheer
coincidence these things happen in life
i was working for the chicago tribune i
was based in dc
in washington so when barack obama was
elected to the senate in 2004
jeff zeleny who was then a reporter with
washington bureau of the tribune
he and i documented obama's first year
in the senate
and i got access that nobody else got
because that was with the quote unquote
hometown newspaper so i got to know him
on a professional
uh you know just in a professional way
but he also got a chance to see
how i worked you know which is you know
i like to say i work with
you know a small footprint and try not
to interfere with what's going on
um and and you know and he saw that i
took my job seriously
so you know skip ahead to four years he
gets elected president and asked me to
you know to be his white house
photographer so that's why it happened
for me
i'd imagine there were campaign
photographs
being taken all the time that was so
that was not you or that was you
2007 is when he started the campaign
because he started actually in february
2007 pretty
you know pretty early and i covered
probably the first three months of the
campaign
and then i quit i quit the trip tribune
because i thought
if they had just been bought by a real
estate magnet and
i didn't like the direction the
newspaper was going
i was uh you know i i just
didn't think that i could stomach it
anymore and even though
i sort of had the inside track to
covering his campaign i just could not
see myself working for the
tribune anymore and i ended up taking a
a teaching job
photojournalism teaching job at ohio
university
um and then i would occasionally as a
freelancer
uh you know hook up with him on the
campaign drill
um so i sort of kept my foot in the door
a little bit
and then he wins in 2008 and then
you get the word hey come back to dc and
become the white house photographer that
must have been quite a call
what was it from brock himself or was
that from someone on his team
you know gibbs was um kind of my main
contact
with obama and you know in robert gibbs
a lot of people
you know just think of him as the uh
press secretary
but gibbs was one of the most
influential aides he was really
like sort of a senior advisor uh as well
as the press secretary so he
he was the one who called me on behalf
of the president-elect
he called me the night before classes
for the winter quarter where they
were supposed to begin and on a sunday
night and so the following
uh morning monday i walked into
my boss at ohio university and told him
that i was
leaving that afternoon for dc and i was
quite
quitting my job i
kind of had given them a heads up that
this might happen but you know you never
know until
until you get that call so then you
proceeded to spend
eight years as the white house
photographer uh
so i mean obviously you would spend a
lot of time in dc so you were very
familiar with the environment
but coming into the white house that
must have been
an incredible journey where
you must have felt like you were
documenting history essentially every
day for uh
for eight years um what was that
adjustment like
um and the other question i'd have is it
seems
completely physically impossible to me
for any one human to cover everything
that happened in the white house so
is there like a whole team of you yeah i
had a staff
um my my approach going in was
um that i was going to be
all in every day because my attitude was
if you were going to document for
history you
a you can't predict when history is
going to happen you know you don't guess
you don't always get noticed bowers know
yes um
but then also in terms of photography
you know i just felt the fleeting
moments
little moments the way he interacts with
certain people
uh if you're not there all the time
you're definitely not gonna make that
picture and
so i wanted to make sure that i was all
there all the time
to make those fleeing moments because i
didn't ever want to miss any
so that's sort of the way i approached
uh the job and i
i you know i knew what i was in for uh i
don't think my wife knew what that's
before um because you know you kind of
put your personal life on hold for
and you know in my case for eight years
but um
you know i i did have a staff so it's
don't feel sorry for me because i could
have
easily you know taken a day off here and
there but
uh you know my attitude was just always
be there
so when does the day start and end for
you in that situation like i feel like
you'd want to live near the white house
just to be able to get there
yeah i didn't live that far i lived
about 15
20 minutes away and um i would try to
get there
you know one of the you know things that
we have to worry about is
staffers that he he doesn't really have
to worry about
is you know you got to commute you got
to get there whereas his commute was you
know two minutes
so but i would try to get there at least
an hour before him
uh he would he would come down to the
oval office
sometime between nine and ten in the
morning uh so i tried to get there
you know about an hour before i did have
responsibilities as the head of my
office and i would try to deal with
those either early in the morning or at
the end of the day
and then i would basically tag along
with him um
all day long until he went home for
dinner
and um you know and sometimes after
dinner he would come back to the west
wing or there'd be
um events uh you know on the state floor
or outside of dc
that he would go to at night and so you
know every day was you know a little
different but
pretty much i would just tag along with
him
you know at least 10 hours a day
sometimes 15 sometimes
longer so you you're documenting him
people like me come in
and people like me you don't really
remember because i met president obama
um let's say either three or four times
something like that
um either in a group or in a collective
setting and you were joking that
like by the sixth picture you might
recognize someone again um i did get a
picture
every time i met him which was it was
kind of nice
it's like it was just you're around him
there oh there were always these
photographers trying to capture the
moment
um so and you don't even realize it when
you're the guest at that moment and so
then you just get the photo later and
you're like incredible
like all of my exchanges uh immortalized
um no you you probably have all sorts of
um crazy experiences and recollections
was there anything that you're
able to share about an experience where
you were like wow that just happened
for me a lot of the the wow moments were
not necessarily like the big event
but more um the the those moments that i
talked about those little moments were
which really um define him as a human
being
you know i mean like for i'll just this
is just a for instance i mean
ben rhodes um who you know was a deputy
national security adviser and
his daughter he he came in with his
daughter like around halloween time one
year
and she was just learning to crawl
and so obama gets down on
the rug of the old office squats down
and gets ella to crawl to him
and then he lies down on his back and
he's lifting her up and
you know those moments are just like i
can't believe this is happening
as i'm photographing this um you know
certainly
the bin laden raid and big historic
events like that obviously
are are also wow in a kind of different
way
where you sort of really feel the weight
of history uh taking place right in
front of you
um so um but you know i mean i think one
of the things
that was advantageous about being
a seasoned photographer photojournalist
is i was sort of able to to keep my
emotions in check
you know and not get so um
high if you will when when these
uh when these big moments are happening
just you know just sort of
try to keep my my level pretty even
so i'm not so overwhelmed by what's
happening that
i'm still able to make you know pictures
[Music]
thank you to skillshare for sponsoring
this episode of yang speaks
skillshare is this awesome online
learning community
where people go to learn from experts
in creative fields they
gain new skills you can really get lost
in your own creative learning i'm
looking at a class called plants
at home uplift your spirit and your
space by the scandinavian christopher
griffin
because there's a certain element of
plants in a home that
actually help and that sounds stupid it
sounds like very like
mom or karen or whatever but like live
laugh love but for real
that totally works we're not that far
removed from uh
you know just running around in the
woods yeah well it's helpful because
i just like buy an ikea plant and like
there's actually a little more art to
that so i'm learning about
various versions of succulents and
whatever the heck that you know i i bet
the ladies love that too you go in
they're like ooh this guy's sensitive
oh yeah good point i water that yeah if
you water that you know what that says
that says responsibility that's what
that says
so if you too want to figure out how to
make your place greener and a million
other potential avenues
for learning and creativity explore
skillshare.com
yang speaks the first 1 000 people to
use our link will get a free trial
of skillshare's premium membership
receive free access to thousands of
classes for a limited time
be one of the first 1000 to sign up at
skillshare.com
yang speaks so most classes are under 60
minutes with short lessons they fit in
your schedule you can do it easily
there's no ads they're always launching
new premium classes and it's less than
10
a month with an annual subscription so
it's cheap it's awesome
it's effective so break up your team
with kind of spontaneous acts of
creativity
go to skillshare.com yang
speaks check it out
[Applause]
you know what yang speaks we are all
about our data being
ours and one way you can protect your
data is by using expressvpn
what's a what's expressvpn vpn stands
for virtual private network
when you beam into the internet using a
server far
far away and no one knows it's you big
companies use it
spies i assume use it cool people who
don't want anyone
selling and reselling their data use it
and you can use it too
it's fast it's easy expressvpn is the
number one rated vpn by wired
verge c net and yang speaks i gotta say
that you know we looked at the field and
said these guys have it
uh there's another perk too is that you
can access content that's
only available in europe
or whatever other country it is like
that
european exclusive content you could be
like beat me to europe
i'm gonna watch people talk in french
so go to expressvpn.com yang to get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free expressvpn.com
yang
[Applause]
you've had a any number of books of
photo books
um seven published books
uh over the last number of years and one
of them shade a tale of two presidents
got a ton of attention
more recently because of a documentary
about your work it came out originally
in 2018
and now it's having a resurgence
it must be incredibly fun and exciting
for you to be
publishing these catalogs of your work
that are touching so many people
even years after the fact the the shade
book
you know would never have come into
existence if donald trump hadn't been
elected president
it really chronicles his first couple
years the craziness
of how he conducted himself in office
and then the and by comparison i would
show photographs and have my
captions of similar situations with
president obama and i think that
contrast
you know it really made people stop and
think about
how crazy this administration is
you know how crazy he is in terms of the
way he behaves in office
yeah the juxtaposition between trump's
tweets and then some photo of
uh barack being a human being
it was it was very art artfully done
uh it's one of the things that makes it
really pressing to figure out why
over 70 million americans voted for
donald trump what's your thinking of why
i mean you know this guy you know the
one thing that he does
good is is market himself even though
most of most of the marketing is based
on
you know lies and uh
untruths yeah there are a couple of
ingredients for me pete
number one is just simple polarization
where
at this point there are a lot of people
who are just like on the republican team
or on the democrat team and
they'll vote for whomever on the basis
of
uh maybe a few key policies i think a
really huge part of it
is that many americans mistrust
what they see as career politicians they
think they're phonies they don't think
they're they're actually there for the
right reasons
and that donald trump for all of his bad
qualities
strikes them as somehow more quote
unquote genuine in a particular way
because
his behavior is more unconstrained in a
different kind of way
do you think do you think that's why you
struck a chord with so many young people
you didn't come at it as a you know as a
politician and and yet
you you got a lot of attention during
during the
the the primaries uh for for good reason
i mean well thank you pete for noticing
uh
there's like a um i think there
there's a desire among some americans
for
a different approach to politics i think
that that
uh antipathy towards politicians is
frankly stronger among republicans than
democrats
i think that there were some democrats
who are very happy to see
an entrepreneur and non-politician like
myself run
but i think that thirst is higher the
republican party
let's put it that way so we talked about
how the
your your uh book shade um has been
boosted tremendously by the documentary
that came out about you
uh the way i see it how did that
documentary come about um so they
approached me about
two years ago uh it was laura dern's
production partner jamie lemons at that
time i was promoting
the shade book actually and
um and i do the you know do these uh
presentations with big
big screens showing the photographs sort
of doing the same thing i kind of do on
instagram
and what i eventually did in the book uh
in front of a live audience and
um she she and evan hayes another
producer who
had done the film uh free solo
came to one of my presentations and i
think they were like okay this is
we got to do something with this and so
it took them probably i don't know two
months to convince me because
i like you know my
privacy and very ironic pete
there you are a fly on the wall for all
these other people and then they want to
end
the subject you know obviously i i had a
following
on instagram but there's still a fair
amount of anonymity when you're
when you're not like it's true you're
not the subject
it's just not the subject so yeah you
know i had to think about it
um and convinced my wife
that it was okay and it seems like you
owe your wife like a great deal pete
you know i just thought that um it was
worth giving up
that some more anonymity um
to try to reach people with this film
because i think you know not everybody's
on
social media and i thought you know a
documentary film could do a really
effective job of
of uh getting you know my message out
what what you know what i've been doing
the last
essentially four years and and throwing
shade
so that's how it came about how did you
feel about the experience i've actually
been the subject of a documentary
myself there are times when it's great
there are times when you regret your
decision to say yes
there are times when you're like i
really do not want to have this camera
following me around right now i don't
want someone asking me about
you know what i'm thinking and feeling
um
so but then at least in my case like i
was very proud of
of the result uh you know it felt like
all of the energy
um and dedication and work paid off
um what was your experience yeah i had
some of that same experience where
uh you know what while you're in it
you're
you're you're there were times when it
was difficult to
say why am i why am i doing this um
and um you know and i didn't have
editorial control
over the film you know it was i tell
people it's not my film i'm just
in it uh but but but i did have some
influence on on what photographs were
were going to be used um
you know once they once they showed me a
rough cut
and i was like well that that's great
but
why don't you consider these pictures
for that section
and so that that that sort of helped me
um you know i think uh feel good about
the the the film as a as an entity as a
whole and and i you know i thought they
did a great job
to i thought you know i i so despite its
main subject
i think it's a great film is the way i
was
when i agreed to do it uh one of the
things i said
is you've got to promise me
you're going to do everything you
possibly can
to get this film released before the
election you know and they they gave me
you know you can't ever say for sure but
they gave me
their word that they would try and and
they did and you know we had some
huge complications because of covet they
kind of had to finish a lot of
production uh and make
um choices based
because of covid where not everybody was
in the room
i mean they were they were you know
doing editing
from you know all over the country
um where you know individual producers
and the director
and the editor were all different places
so that made it really challenging
and uh i mean the the the final
interviews they did with me
uh we did over zoom like this and then
yeah
they sent me like an hd camera
um that i hooked up myself
so that while they were interviewing me
it would be on this you know hd
quality film um so there were like kind
of things like that that they had to do
there are a couple of the interviews
that they had scheduled that they had to
scrap
but for the most part we were able to
that i say we i mean they were able to
uh pull put it together uh you know
despite
covid challenge challenges
[Music]
[Applause]
all right it's almost december you
haven't bought anyone a gift
but if you're looking for a gift that
they're gonna love
we recommend raycon wireless earbuds
these things are awesome they work
they're comfortable they cancel out
noise
mine are blue and they look badass this
is why i love them
i felt cooler when i put them on a
little like back
like felt futuristic if you will uh and
they work just as well
like they work just as good as they look
if that makes any sense like that you're
not compromising quality for all that
style
they are the smart buy in that they're
just as cool and high quality as those
other things but they don't break the
bank like those other things so go
to buy raycon dot com slash yang today
to get 20
off your recon order this offer is
available for a limited time only you
don't want to miss it
you can get this stuff for the holidays
for your favorite someone and they will
love you for it trust
us on that i love mine zach loves his
that's by raycon.com yang to get 20
off your raycons by raycon.com
[Applause]
how does andrew yang look so good it's
not easy
uh but part of it is wearing awesome
gear
i'm actually not that hip or anything
but i do enjoy
my clothes from outer known uh i'm
wearing a t-shirt right now
they're comfortable they fit well
they're well made
and one thing that makes you feel good
about them is you know that they're made
in a way
that's good for the environment they
provide living wages to people so
like you feel conscientious it was
founded by pro surfer
and 11 time world champion kelly slater
it's got that vibe it's got kind of that
beachy surfer vibe
so if this sounds like something you
want to check out go to
outernow.com today and if you like the
clothes you can enter my code yang at
checkout and you get 25
off your first full price order wow
that's autonomous.com
o-u-t-e-r-k-n-o-w-n-dot-com
use my code yang at checkout for 25 off
check them out today i don't know.com
and don't forget promo code yang for 25
off i don't know if you ever watch the
office
andrew but there's an episode where
michael scott steve carrell
uh puts on his jeans on like casual
friday and he's like dancing around and
putting it like shaking his butt and
putting it in everybody's face because
he's like so happy and comfortable in
his jeans
that is honestly a version of what i do
when i wear
i don't know jeans they're freaking
awesome they look good they feel good uh
so get that feeling get that warm cozy
feeling i don't know.com
promo code yang get your 25 off
[Applause]
so again you may be the most famous
photojournalist in the world
uh for good reason i mean you're
incredibly skilled and talented
there's something uh ineffable about
what talented photographers can do
uh it's wild i actually have no
understanding
of how someone like you does what you do
versus someone else who's also talented
but there's actually something of a
difference and this is a long-winded way
of not just singing your praises
but also trying to identify the process
that made you
you and whether that's actually still
going to be possible
for future photo journalists because
we're in an era now where you have
someone like me i've got like a device
and i'm just taking i'm sure terrible
pictures i've been a terrible
photographer
like my entire life really but i feel
like now with technology
i'm the norm like i think that there are
a lot of terrible photographers because
the pictures are so
um ephemeral seeming it's like i can
take
10 at the same time so who really cares
if i've done something
specific or captured something um
magical
if i as i'm surmising the future of
photojournalism is not exactly robust
like what can or should we do to
change that or help support it i mean
the good thing about
uh today where we are
is that um
any person that wants to be a
photojournalist
can have a forum to present their work
because of the internet
they can they can do it on instagram
they can do it on the website
they can um post their own pictures
and they they can they can almost be
like their own um
you know uh photo newspaper if you will
the bad thing about it is how do they
get how do they
sustain that funding right
it's um uh nobody's paying you
necessarily to to do that and as you say
newspapers have cut back positions
i live in madison wisconsin now they
only have four staff photographers where
like you know it's probably
[Music]
i think back in the day they probably
had 12 or 15.
um you know the large newspapers have
cut
staff 2000 newspapers themselves have
gone out of business
so you know you talked about how the
chicago tribune at one time was getting
bought by some hedge fund back in
um 07 or 08 or whatever it was
at this point the newspaper industry has
gotten rolled up and consolidated into
a handful of operators that are
themselves owned by private equity firms
who are now ringing them for cash
um so they're not a growth operation i
just want to let people know 2000
papers have disappeared that we know of
and that number is going up all the time
no and i think it's you know that
that fact is playing out during covid in
the sense that
if if you remember after after 9 11
it happened in one town well two towns
dc but primarily one town
the new york times the hometown
newspaper did these amazing portraits
of people who had died uh you know
the the more than two thousand people
that had died
um and it you know you really connected
with them
as as people who had lost their life
because of this national tragedy
well we've now had what the equivalent
of 73
911s or something like that
and local newspapers are not doing those
kinds of stories
because they don't have oh wow the the
the kind of bandwidth that that
they should have and and profiling
people in their community that have died
because of covid
it's affecting us that we're where you
know we we think of these
people who have died and we don't really
know them unless you personally know
somebody that died
there's not the kind of connection to
this tragedy that we had we all had with
911 because of what the new york times
was doing with these portraits the loss
of local journalism and photojournalism
specifically has a real
profound impact um and i certainly would
not have
drawn the comparison you just made um
but it's
very very powerful and apt you know you
think about all the people that have
lost their lives that
uh in new york times did that headline
where it just had their names
and that was very dramatic um but you
know
like as we all know a photograph is much
much more
uh powerful than a name
yeah and you know and we we don't see
many of the local newspapers getting
inside
you know hospitals and showing that
you know what the trauma that's going on
and continues to go on for months
um for for whatever reason i mean early
on we saw that in the new york times
washington post some other
big newspapers but we're not seeing that
by and large in
in daily newspapers across the country
so so people are
you know listening to what you know the
person who shall
not be named telling us how it's all a
hoax and you know
it's it's we're right around the corner
and
you know part of it is that the local
newspapers and
local tv stations are not covering this
stuff
on their local level one of the things i
was going to talk about
photojournalism specifically um
even when i was teaching back in 2007
or 2008 i was telling the students
that the staff jobs are going away and
you've got to rethink
you know if you really want to do photo
journals and how you're going to
stay afloat and you know because most
most people end up being
freelancers and so you need to know how
to run a business
and you also need to understand that
in order to make it financially you've
got to
you've got to branch out and not think
just about doing photojournalism
but you've got to survive by doing other
kinds of photo
photography to supplement your income
whether that's
shooting weddings or portraits or a
little commercial work or something
doesn't mean that you give up doing
photojournalism
but to stay afloat you just gotta branch
out a little bit
um and you know another just sort of
like a little off topic but
you know you talk about yourself with
your iphone or whatever
kind of smartphone you have making
pictures and
you know i would argue that a
professional photographer who is good at
their craft
will do a better job than you however
should definitely better than me however
citizen journalism is
is important to it it's been important
especially the last five five years in
documenting
um things that are going on
i mean think about this the whole black
lives matter
uh movement uh just got
ratcheted up so much because of a 17
year old high school girl
who had the presence of mind to film the
whole george floyd incident
and it wasn't like one of those videos
that you see where it's like you can't
quite tell what's going on
this girl held her [ __ ] together
the entire time not knowing that he was
gonna die
um but just stayed with it for seven
minutes
you know and you know i will actually
reach out to the biden people
uh at some point and say she she
deserves the presidential medal of
freedom
she really does um and that's just some
kid
high school kid with a phone
that had a major impact on this year
oh a major impact uh hopefully on
u.s history really i mean if if reform
does occur
uh or even i mean even if it doesn't i
guess that would tell another story but
it would still be historic
um it's true it's one of the things that
i've always known is that these things
are happening
it's just now we can see them and we can
see them because of
smartphones and these new technologies
so they're definitely
massive value adds and virtues but you
were casting photojournalism as like
look you need to be able to pay the
bills
um and so as you know i ran on universal
basic income so i guess you can imagine
a world where everyone just had more
money
flowing into their hands that more
people could become
photojournalists vocationally or
you know as a way um to express
themselves
and share pictures with the world um
there is a photojournalist named chris
arnaud who
left his wall street job and then became
a photographer of
working class americans i don't know if
you've seen his work but he was doing it
purely as a passion and then now it has
taken on a life of its own because he's
very talented and he's been documenting
in many ways like the wreckage of
american society
but it makes me think of that like if
you were to free people from the
confines
of um needing to make money to pay their
bills in any given month i'm sure a lot
more people would want to
uh pursue photojournalism and
documenting the lives of the people
around them
yeah no i i think i think that's true so
on your side are you optimistic or
pessimistic about um
both the field that you're you're uh
possibly like the walking embodiment of
it at this point uh photojournalism and
the country writ large given i feel like
you've seen more than just about any of
us
uh like in terms of both the best and
the the worst
uh of this country yeah no i i i
am optimistic um i
i you know i sort of implore the
photojournalist of today
given the propensity of the you know the
current president of the outgoing
president
to uh label
the press the enemy of the people and
and you know this whole
fake news stuff you know which has been
really dangerous and it's going to be
hard to shake that
um and i think that how that affects
photojournalists is they've got to be
absolutely
um uh ethical
and honest and and not you know
not do anything uh to call in
the call and question the authenticity
of their photographs this is one thing
that that's going to be particularly
important in an era of deep fakes where
you can just
doctor everything one thing that uh like
uh
an expert pushed me towards which i
thought was really fascinating
was that you can create watermarks on
individuals cameras so in your case you
take photos
and if it says pizzas all of a sudden it
becomes like you know part of history
i'm sure that there are all sorts of
fake pizzas out there
that tried to to to uh
pawn off their work um so this expert
uh suggested that one of the things that
we need in order to establish
truth is that there actually is
a way to tie every photo to uh the
photojournalist through their device
you essentially have a watermark on the
camera and said this really was pete
souza's work
and it's uh unaltered um and that in
some ways photojournalists could become
like the last
safeguard on whether what we're seeing
is real or not
yeah i mean i think there's people
smarter than me that are working on this
and i think i think it's it's important
but it's also important to know
you know you need to know your source
like if you're on twitter or
instagram whatever um i was really
offended the other day when i posted
something on
a new picture it was at protest here at
the state capitol
uh and there was an argument going on
between some trump people and some
biden people and some
one of my followers you know just
their comment was this is obviously
photoshopped
you know and that connotation photoshop
means you know it was
fabricated and i like really went after
this person because
if you know me anybody that knows me
that was a real front integrity i would
never you know mess with a photo like
that
and so that really pissed me off um
and it's it's i appreciate my other most
of my followers because they all come to
my defense
you know they they they know me and they
know what they're looking at is
authentic and real and and not altered
in any way
um but you know it it not every picture
from every photographer has that same
degree of authenticity and then that
i mean what you're talking about i think
could be an important way to
to to you know verify that what you're
looking at is for real
yeah not again not everyone's pete souza
but if everyone had like this stamp
where it's essentially like i and the
device stand by this
and it's unaltered and the rest of it it
could be incredibly important
the fact that anyone would accuse you of
that just seems apparently ridiculous to
me and it's a sign of the time it's back
to that mistrust that we're talking
about
a little bit earlier so if people want
to see the way i see it
this important documentary with you as
the subject
what's the best way that they can see it
uh
from their own home or i guess possibly
in the theater though it's probably more
likely to be streamed
i don't know what theaters it's in right
now um
but you can see it from home and peacock
which is the new
nbc streaming service it's free on
peacock and you can sign up
for peacock for free so if
you know if you want to watch it for
free that's the way to do it
it's also on demand at you know the
usual platforms like itunes
prime and a whole bunch of others well
it's certainly money well spent we are
very hungry for excellent content
and uplifting content nowadays and i
dare say that you're responsible for
more uplifting content than maybe anyone
else walking the planet
uh so congratulations to you and your
team
for telling your story it's really
incredible they don't make them like you
um anymore and hopefully we can make it
so that there there will be other pete
souzas maybe who knows maybe this uh
um lucky soul that ends up being the
biden photographer
uh will will end up uh carving out a
legacy similar to yours which i dare say
would be like
the highest aim that they could aspire
to
uh so really thank you for helping us
all experience history at a higher level
thank you for giving us like a window
into
a white house that was like the defining
white house for so many of us
and on a personal level thank you for
taking such
exceptional photos of me when i was in
the white house
that it made me feel better about
myself and my presence in the world for
years well
before there because there was never
going to be like an andrew young
presidential run um you know like
i can prove to anyone that i had no
intention of running for president
simply by the fact that my organization
had no operations in either iowa new
hampshire
and had operations like a lot of other
places um so as like an ordinary
civilian
getting that portrait that you you did
of me
like it was it was really empowering and
energizing it was wild there was the one
with me and obama yes but then there was
like a simple headshot you took of me
ended up um ended up being the jacket
photo on my first book
actually you've touched so many lives in
so many ways mostly from people that
have experienced your work
you know just seeing a photo they might
not even know you took it just like the
the
you know like major photo of obama that
um everyone recognizes
uh you know you've touched at this point
i like hundreds of millions of lives uh
so thank you
personally and thank you on behalf of
the world for
helping us understand our world uh and
humanity a bit better
well thanks andrew i appreciate it and i
you know i appreciate what you're doing
uh matter of fact uh on my street uh you
have a couple of
members of the yang gang and they still
have their bumper stickers on their cars
so well please say hey to the for me say
that andrew yang appreciates the heck
out of them
and check out the way i see it uh this
incredible documentary about pete and
his work of the last number of years it
really does
um elevate your understanding of both
the kind of
work that a photojournalist does but
also a bit more about what's going on
uh in our country today uh
congratulations to you and the team for
making it
thanks i appreciate it and thanks for
having me on thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation if
you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode